one in mesquite
any thunderstorms that
fall on your house will be ending in
through the evening hours the heating of
the sun after sunset will diminish the
possibility and then partly cloudy skies
still going to be on the humid side
tomorrow mostly sunny some afternoon
clouds still going to be a bit humid i
mean we're not going to be bone dry
don't don't think that south winds at 10
to 15 miles an hour highs tomorrow
they're going to be a mix of upper 90s
and low 100s with the low 100s as you
might guess on the east side of the
valley and regionally 90s will
predominate mesquite death valley
loftland should make it to the 100
degree mark so here we go morning sun
afternoon clouds tomorrow more sun and
clouds on wednesday by late thursday a
chance for some thunderstorms and then a
chance of afternoon thunderstorms on
friday saturday sunday monday this is
getting redundant but you can see
temperatures will be dropping humidity
will be up it's not a sure thing never
is but it looks like the monsoon will be
coming back and paying us another visit
after taking a break i guess seven days
of vegas was too much you just had had
to get out of here christian